i want to talk about the word [ __ ]
what have you learned about the word
[ __ ] recently
okay so
i was
doing a bit of research into why things
become offensive because it just became
curious to me i wanted to know why are
some things offensive and other things
not offensive
and i began to sort of think about the
word [ __ ]
and
this is a word that's quite offensive i
mean most people would consider it
pretty offensive you know especially in
polite society i mean there are a lot of
people who use it in jest but but
there's a lot of people who find it
offensive and um
you know if you ask these people why
they find it offensive and they'll say
oh it's because you know
it was historically used to refer to
mentally disabled people
um
which i think is a perfectly reasonable
explanation
but
then you ask these same people
do they find the word idiot offensive or
the word imbecile offensive or the word
[ __ ] offensive or the word [ __ ]
offensive
and
most people don't find these words
offensive i mean a few people find
credit inoffensive but most people don't
find idiot or embassy or [ __ ]
particularly offensive you know they use
it's very these are common words
but the thing is if you look at the
history of these words they were also
used to refer to mentally disabled
people that's their origins their
origins is actually they were used as
categorizations of mentally disabled
people
and i
point out this example of
the queen's first cousins
who were
officially diagnosed
as imbeciles
and as a result of that the royal family
faked their deaths
and basically locked them away in a care
home
for the rest of their lives
and they were and when they died the
royal family didn't even attend their
funeral
uh you know it was pretty tragic story
but like um it goes to show that you
know the word embassy was used even for
members of the royal family if they had
if they were mentally disabled
and so
there's this weird sort of disparity
between the word [ __ ] and the other
words which mean exactly the same thing
but which are not offensive and you've
got to ask yourself what's the purpose
for this why is the word [ __ ]
offensive but all these other words
which were used again for exactly the
same reason why they're not offensive
and i i was looking into the history of
these words and the only conclusion that
i could come to was that
it was a purely arbitrary decision
so a group of people you know a group of
intellectuals one day decided that the
word was offensive
and
they said as much to the people and you
know them i don't know where where it
was officially established but gradually
it became offensive to use that word
and so
we chose we we all collectively decided
to have a specific emotional reaction to
a certain word but not to other words
with the same meaning
and that strikes me as very strange
because
it means that a lot of the outrages a
lot of the things that outrageous
are purely arbitrary they're just
they're just arbitrarily chosen
you know there's no real reason why we
should be
upset or offended by a certain word we
just choose to be offended by it
and we choose to not be offended by
other words you know so
this i think is a it was a big insight
for me because it really opened my eyes
to
exactly what outrage is a lot of outrage
is just manufactured it's purely
manufactured you don't need to be angry
about any of the things and you know or
at least most of the things that you
you're angry about you know in in
everyday life
they're not rooted in anything more
solid
than simply people making choices in the
past you also use that example of
uh is it the naacp
oh right yeah yeah i mean yeah so this
is another thing that i've never
understood is that somehow the word
colored people became offensive
and you had to use the word the term
people of color instead
i've never understood why i've never
really understood why i mean i did ask
somebody who was pretty sort of woke and
they said to me um
that it's because when you use the word
when you use colored people you're
you're centering color but when you use
people of color you're centering people
because the first word is people rather
than color
and so that's a [ __ ] tenuous very
tenuous exactly i don't understand it
you know and
i have no problem with people calling me
a coloured person i don't find it
affects what's your heritage
indian yep
yeah i'm indian punjabi so
i i don't have any problem with
with people calling me uh a colored
person you know and i don't think most
colored people do
i don't think most of us do have a
problem with it but what's really
interesting is the naacp is the national
association for the advancement of
colored people is that right yeah so
what that's like is kind of like a
fossilized record of what linguistic
territory used to be acceptable and
because they haven't updated their
branding to move in line with lexically
what's now part of the green light red
light system
yeah they're they're kind of this
fossilized record of oh
that used to be okay
but now it's not so if there was the
n-double
a-r-p
right for [ __ ] people
you go okay
hang on
is that a pejorative are you using that
to to refer to this entire what about
the cretins in the room and what about
the morons in the room what about them
where are they so yeah it's so that yeah
the thing is is that linguistic all this
kind of linguistic
[Music]
re-retribalizing of territory
is that it just creates outrages
where outrages don't need to exist
we've already got enough things to be
outraged about in this world plenty of
things to be outraged about in this
world you know if you you've just got to
switch on the news to see what's going
on you know
in some parts of the world
but
the thing is is that uh
instead of like trying to do something
about the things that outrageous the
things that we should be outraged about
some of the injustices that are
occurring for instance you know the
concentration camps in china for
instance
um
instead we just
sort of kind of redraw the territory of
language and create new outrages out of
it out of nothing
we create new outrages out of nothing
and
it just doesn't make any sense to me i
just don't understand why why people
would choose to be upset
over
you know the use of words is that a
little bit of so many other things to be
outrageous about say is law coming back
in again the fact that you can
create outrage and posture the fact that
you are
helping that this is something that
you're really bothered about but you
know that by pushing back against
colored people or the word [ __ ] that
really the battlefront that you're
playing on has pretty low stakes yeah
well the thing is is that if you're a
member of an ideology and you're
dedicated to a certain cause then you
have an invested interest in making that
cause seem like a bigger issue than it
actually is
so if you're an anti-racist then you
have a vested interest in making racism
seem bigger than it actually is because
that makes your task and your job and
your mission
more important than it actually is and
that's why i think a lot of
people who are sort of these who just
define themselves as anti-racists
will constantly cause
they'll constantly create new forms of
racism
because they need it you know i think
somebody's said i've forgotten who it
was that they said that the
the demand for racism exceeds the supply
you know
and um
that's basically what's causing a lot of
this kind of it's driving a lot of this
these new
outrages and these new offenses because
people need racism in order to feel like
they've got something to fight against
and if you look at you know yes
if you look statistically there there
does seem to be some
racial disparities but those racial
disparities
are not as big as they're portrayed in
the mainstream media
and the mainstream media exaggerates
these because it needs to feel like
there's a big struggle that it's
fighting against
um and so that's i think probably the
explanation for why
the word
colored people is now offensive because
we need more and more things to be
racist
so that we can feel more anti-racist
when we fight against them what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace